with this furry
20 joshua
sleep through first five
involved
frosting
the whole point of enjoyment weapons is
they modify weapons to produce power
and stability
and control of the body they're not
really weapons
in their own right per
say um
so the idea is to try and get
try and get uh
smooth
and controlled movement in time
should start slow
and then
if you get the right move with your
speeding power increase try and get
speedy power
correct movement you just end up with a
mess
okay
so
i've i'm not a fan of standing right
behind every game
you know because it's best to take it do
it in your own time so i'll demonstrate
and then you're going to
get in your own space and doing your own
time and speed
so the first saburi is uh
ski with level thrust so it starts here
so
[Music]
in this posture
this is in front something like a guard
posture
take down here
okay this foot is now 45 degrees
um to the posture i'm keeping this here
i have to the joker has to go to the
side
because if you have here it comes you
know hits something that comes back at
you
you're gonna be in trouble okay
and
the other thing is it rotates a little
bit
so
[Music]
as i thrust this rope
safe
so this is a reputation
it slides through the hand
basic thrusts use the whole length of
the joe
if you're doing uh
if you're actually using it to attack or
defending the real you're
probably on the other side
just do that
but if you start with that
it's
kind of your body
won't work or anything
let's say chocolate ski
this is parallel to the ground
breathe out
to the thrust
[Music]
okay